at Pinecrest inspirada in Henderson I
had the honor to visit Miss gunob's
class to chat with bright fifth grader
and met with the articulate 8th graders
in Miss Chavez's room we talked about
broadcasting journalism they asked
insightful questions and each class did
mock newscast where they got a feel for
what we do here at 8 news now the staff
at pinecrestins brought us his career
day is part of their Vision to prepare
students who are college-bound and
career ready and this is career day over
at Gene Ward Elementary School the kids
showing up with a list of questions to
ask our eight news now investigators
about their jobs investigator reporter
Vanessa Murphy and photojournalist Scott
Koss said the kids were thoughtful fun
and they had a really great time
what do you like about career day I like
how we can have fun and and meet all the
guests what do you want to be when you
grow up I want to be a YouTuber that
helps people do you want to work in TV
news no why not because I want to be a
singer instead because I love to sing